good morning millennial welcome to the
morning toast wait welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome to a morning
Joe's by the way that is a great theme
song do you want to do it for real and
underrated that the principle from that
movie it's Tobias from Tobias V&K and
even more underrated is that he's
married to the girl from sister of the
Traveling Pants the emo one and even
more of your night he'd answer yeah
they're married amber tamblyn Tamblyn
tanning drink her breast milk wait even
more ironic is that he is also like an
alleged assault her you're lying again
and she's like super outspoken and like
a big like feminist and it's just like
awkward cuz she's like married to an
assaulter now and she like was it
assault or races I don't remember I
think it was assault her
okay well that sucks
yeah um welcome good morning Millennials
if we seem so organized today it's
because we're on top of our [ __ ] we have
a new intern who came highly recommended
she was not foisted onto him right no
she is um Harvard Business great grab
top of her class but like it's hard top
of her class she had offers at Goldman
Sachs Morgan Stanley right
NASA SpaceX but she obviously decided to
turn all those down and take the clear
winner in an unpaid internship and you
know what it's been so rewarding for her
already she got these pair of headphones
and she just looks to be on top of the
world so snitches on the toast permanent
way but not really on the toast more
like next adjacent snitch adjacent to
the toast but we're excited she's here
she's been super helpful for the first
10 minutes let's hope she keeps it up
all summer yeah but it looks like she's
on her phone so we'll see she's reading
comments she swears I know I am she's
she's monitoring um also what we have
such a crazy week and we just need you
to bear with us like because I'm taking
full responsibility for the [ __ ] show
that's gonna be this week but it's gonna
be like an epic [ __ ] show because I'm
only here Monday and Wednesday because
right after this I'm headed to Philly
for for Seoul that shows tonight
tomorrow sorry you can't buy tickets
then I'm back here Wednesday and we have
none other than Golnesa Loch NESA
in the building super excited to talk to
her about Shaw's a little scared but
really excited a second because I feel
like this
is gonna be great for her so it'll be a
very positive conversation because I
watch last week's episode it was so good
these new brother and sister I'm sure
coupled I didn't want you on the plane
I've been saving for my and them skiing
was really the content that I need it
she's fantastic
Oh is she yes so when I'm not here
tomorrow I'm very upset because I have
FOMO that I'm gonna be missing this but
I'm really happy for the show you know
when for the show is a win for me I
guess whatever it is true we have big
Rach joining us tomorrow and it's just
perfect timing because tonight is the
final rows of becca season so we're
gonna have a real seasoned expert
sitting in my chair another this is the
chair of seasoned desk experts this is
true so rachel lindsey will be here
tomorrow and then wednesday we have loch
nesa
thursday we haven't figured it out yet
I'm working on something hopefully Ben
is available to co-host with me because
that would be really fun and that's when
I'm in Palm Beach which tickets
available Carl calm the idea sold-out
but there's a couple GA left Friday is
not nailed down yet but it's almost and
I just wanna get you guys excited but
don't get your hopes up because you know
things change
hopefully heather me may and will
finally be on the toes and I'll just
have FOMO about that too but I do on
your week away I have one day available
and she did say that she's gonna be in
New York that week so hopefully I'll be
able to get her also fantastic so it's
good because you know the pros and the
cons cons you're not gonna be here but
pros we are more than making up for it
yeah with very fun co-hosts no and
that's what we end today we have a guest
Dominic pin from wax will be coming on a
little bit later so if you have any
questions obviously make sure to drop
them on our latest Instagram tweet at us
by the way we need the wags T like I
feel like they gave us nothing in the
offseason and she is here to just give
us everything and I'm very much officer
double double entendre anyways we have a
jam-packed show for you today we're
toasters because we know you guys need
our device and we have been remiss in
our dear toaster dude and if you guys
don't know but if you're new by the way
be beginning so many like new people
like I keep getting tweeted out like oh
man I just discovered the morning shows
I don't know how you just discovered a
because they literally don't stop
talking about it neither do you but like
welcome we have a lot of newbies and so
for those who don't know dear toasters
is our weekly well we try to do it
weekly but we always forget
advice segment so if you emailed your
toasters at gmail.com we will answer
some of your most troubling questions
and I just wanna say I threw a bunch of
them last night and y'all are boring as
hell like I want more I want more
interesting ones I did dig deep to find
some semi interesting ones it's always
about just like work or like boyfriend
and it makes me
sort of happy to know that you guys are
doing okay like that's true those aren't
that big and I just want good thanks for
the toaster so I would I would love to
live in a world where we have no dear
toasters yeah where everyone's happy but
at the same time like hit us with a
couple more interesting advice but I got
dug through the weeds and I got some
good ones and we'll be doing that a
little bit later on but not before we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
we have a very well-rounded group of
stories for you today we're not gonna
talk about how Maggie and Mark will turn
37 even though she did by the way she is
older than Kate and William or no or
like around the same age is a great
appetite in fact check it yeah so
interesting I know what else I wanted to
fact check and we'll get into this the
age difference between Courtney Witt
between Scott and Sophia versus Courtney
munis yeah because I think it's actually
the same we need to dive deep into
that's our second story oh okay
she's a year older than Prince William
oh my god Margo just fact-checked it for
us I think we forgot we had a
fact-checker so when they go around the
table at Thanksgiving like in birth
order yeah she goes first to say what
she's thankful for that really is so
bizarre I don't know if there will ever
come a time where I'll stop talking
about Meghan Mark all do you know any me
no and I hope not be I think this is the
way people were with Princess Diana like
Kate I couldn't stop talking about when
it was happening but haven't spoken
about her in a while because she's just
like normal and like lives her life like
I will never stop talking about I and
Markel I don't think the obsession will
ever run dry but as people who are
devoted to premium content we very much
appreciate her okay first up Demi Lovato
has spoken out since her overdose she
released a lengthy statement on
Instagram and I'm going to read the
whole thing for you because what are you
her words deserve to be hurt okay I
thought it was like a little generic I
do I'm gonna just you cliff notes no you
do it I've always been transparent about
my journey with addiction what I've
learned is that this illness is not
something that disappears or fades with
time it is something that I must
continue to overcome and have not done
yet
I want to thank God for keeping me alive
and well to my fans I am forever
grateful for all your love and support
throughout this week and beyond your
positive thoughts and prayers have
helped me navigate through this
difficult time I want to thank my family
my team and the staff at Cedar sinai who
have been by my side this entire time
without them I wouldn't be here writing
this letter to all of you I now need
time to heal and focus on my sobriety
and road to recovery the love you have
all shown me I will never be forgotten
and I look forward to the day where I
can say I came out on the
side I will keep I will keep fighting
heart Demi I don't know I think that
this gave me like a vibe that she didn't
write it which I totally understand
because like she's busy like honestly
writing a statement is like not a
priority right now and it shouldn't be
but this probably is like a lot of her
like true fans is like need to hear from
her but I mean there's no way that she
wrote this it was like so publicist T
and I don't care I just like I read it
and what I got a notification there like
Demi spoke out and I was like oh and
then I saw it I'm like I have to be
honest I've seen this statement so many
times now I saw when she posted it it's
not on the toast I posted it - we posted
it at the exact anyway yes we do that
all the time we both run the morning
thanks right somebody's breaking like
one of us gets it like 10 seconds before
and like they'll like start to come in
so you have to delete the other one
which was fine but this is the first
time I actually read it
oh yeah no anyway I bet the first time
I'm hearing and you know it's very
cookie cutter she said what she had to
say I'm just I'm thinking of her I'm
with her I know she's not on her phone
right now writing a note to us right but
her people are and that's important and
that's good enough I just want her fans
to be okay too because I feel like I'm
an adult and I can I can handle this so
I feel like some of my fans can did you
see that like Atlantic City memorial she
was scheduled to do a show there like a
lot of the people still showed up and
they just like hung out and saying Demi
that's actually very cute yeah no it
wasn't you sounds fun because like a
concert could really just be press play
on an iPod right no one would know the
difference
you should I say sometimes concerts are
pressing play on an iPad right yeah like
I said like the comments on her and
ceramic this is not my favorite part but
like what I'm really enjoying is
watching the outpouring of love from
literally every single celebrity like
there isn't one person who hasn't has
Kim said anything I think so okay
they're just there is it I just love
like watching all the celebrities just
like back her up
this young there demonstrate one
celebrity I don't think that could
garner this much like outpouring of love
from every celebrity from like every
walk of life like music from reality TV
and I love how everyone loves her but
yet she's not boring you know usually
has to be like a boring plain person in
order to be liked by everyone right but
she's very outspoken dynamic she's on
those late-night Twitter rants she is
and people still love her and you know
what get you a girl who can do both
get you a girl who can do both we'll
continue to update this story as it
develops but for now I feel like she
really needs privacy and I'm gonna do my
best to give it to her like only up to
like only talk about Imogen when does
she say when there's something new to
say I realize that we jumped into the
past five before like you know me
talking about myself for a while which
is what I usually like to do and I
didn't really get to talk about my trip
do you want to talk about it because you
didn't ask me because I asked him in the
car yeah you did when we talking the car
it's bad
it ruins the show but then we show up
here and we're not supposed to talking
and it's weird like we're being fake
yeah we are but like we ruin all of our
good convo okay
how was Columbia it was good honestly
being there at the same time as boat
from hell just like in the same country
was just like such an ecstatic so
amazing for me and there was no one
around me who could like feel how crazy
it was yeah because the wedding was one
of Ben's I mean we're friends with him
too but it really is like Ben's friend
so it was a lot of boys and like my
girlfriends weren't there my my friend
Abe was there but he doesn't watch our
house in New York Wow
I know he's a boy don't like him though
is it I feel like he would really
appreciate like this oh he would but
like specialness he's just like I'm a
boy can't watch you know like it's ooh
can't [ __ ] and he would love it but so
no one really like it could get how
excited I was to be there at the time of
the boat from hell ride but it was great
like honestly I spent a hundred dollars
the whole weekend like I was there for
four days it's just so crazy like the
difference between living in New York
and living in Bogota like I can't I have
a question for you so you've been
traveling you were traveling a lot like
you have long plane rides did you listen
to the toast
okay such a great question I have the
patron episode of you and Jane the
downloaded on my phone because I just
how many flights and I downloaded before
my Phoenix flight but before my Phoenix
flight I was delayed seven hours and
there was only one flight out of New
York and I got on it and they upgraded
me to first class so like I was
literally so happy that I spent the
whole plane ride just looking out the
window and smiling and feeling grateful
to be on this plane and be alive that I
was so busy being happy that I couldn't
but that's about Phoenix that was a
while ago you know so I have it on my
and I'm like I'm gonna listen to it but
I know I don't
okay just curious and I've been on the
plane twice when it's on and I try to
stream it but the Wi-Fi is not doable no
it's just like at your
be like commuting yes long stretches
yeah I'm that's when people usually
enjoy the toast I'm just curious if
you're actually a toast consumer
yourself no I'm not because I only like
to watch the toast I don't like to
listen I hate the sound of my own voice
and like sometimes like I don't really
like to watch me so if I'm on it I've
never watched an episode that I'm on
ever I know you'd like to watch it every
day I know what we first started I used
to watch it back like game tapes like to
see how we could get there and now this
is just who we are and it seems like you
guys it's not getting better
we're doing okay but okay so I flew al
Bianca which is like the airline of
bogut on I just have to say terrible
terrible airline and not that I expected
much just horrible customer service me
and then flew back six hours with no air
conditioning Ben was dying he kept
lifting up his shirt and making me feel
the sweat between his rolls like it was
so like it was so disgusting but they
had amazing movies guess what I watched
room
what's your number yeah they had it oh
my god
I watched such an amazing movie this
weekend that I have to tell you about me
too me too
okay wait so I watch what's your number
and what your number is one of the most
underrated romantic comedies of all time
right up there with the other woman I
couldn't agree more and then at the end
they played neon lights by Natasha
Bedingfield's I was like holy [ __ ] I
love this album then I started listening
to the album because I had like
forgotten about it
and that was like the first time in my
life I ever listened to an album in full
and like really loved it so I was just
like I was on a high on the way there
and I said I'm excited for an eighth who
like I never get to see me just have
like such quality time together and he
was watching this movie and I have just
finished my like dumb romantic comedy
and he's watching that movie with John
Krasinski and Emily a fireplace he let
me I put in a headphone we were together
for like the last 40 minutes and
honestly last four nights is all you
need to say they can't talk exactly
Jacki
it is the craziest movie ever
I hadn't know anybody was about it's a
good technically a horror movie but yeah
it's like suspense it was [ __ ] wild
like I was shook on the plane like
there's just this one scene everyone it
was like the birth scene where she has
to give birth in silence yes I know that
was the thing I just saw it in the
commercial doesn't like that sounds
crazy basically the point of the movie
is that like these people took over the
world and can't talk you can't get a
sound it if you do these like gremlins
come out and eat you and their daughter
is deaf and it's like Jackie it's such a
[ __ ] wild movie and I don't even want
to watch it from the beginning I'm like
satisfied with the experience that I had
but then on the way back the flight
never ended never [ __ ] ended and I've
been putting off watching room because
Ben watch it on a play next to me once
and he was so distraught by
it and then like I know but it's about
and it just seems like a [ __ ] sick
disgusting movie like my worst nightmare
yes and like I've just been putting it
off and like I know it's a good movie
but like why don't want to get myself a
Pitt but I'm on this planet I'm like I
had nothing to do but I guess give
myself a Pitt and I watched it and I
just have to say a couple things but
don't spoil it because I think it should
be the next host movie of the woman Oh
Mike because I've never seen it and as
trembley's number one fan I need to see
it all I was gonna say was that I'm
really shocked that Jacob Tremblay was
not nominated for an Oscar and like she
was great what's her name brie Larson
brie Larson I was gonna say Alison Brie
but she was great and she definitely
deserved to win too but like just
comparatively I thought he was stronger
stronger and the fact that he was and
I'm needed was shocking it just goes to
show the ageism that exists in Hollywood
totally okay we can recap it let's make
it this week's movie of the week no no
we have we have two little children
we're gonna discuss on one takes they
haven't had a chance to watch it yet
then next week is the founder it's too
important not to and then next week is
room someone wrote on the stream don't
look I saw it with the quiet place in
theaters and someone brought their baby
because it was a silent movie the baby
was crying and like that would sucked
you know like I guess bringing your baby
the movies is probably hard cuz it's so
loud like their ears can't handle it but
you bring your baby to the movies
because it's a quiet film that's nice
artists so those are the next two movies
of the week we'll keep you posted on
them little children we discussed on
Wednesday I watched this weekend
speaking of Anna Faris being fantastic
overboard no Amaro he looks [ __ ]
dumbest here's the thing we started
watching it it's dumb as hell like the
dialogue is so bad and I guess it's a
remake yeah I think you would have some
like it they would remake it cuz it was
a good film to begin with no half the
movies in Spanish because like there's a
lot of spanish-speaking people so it's a
lot of subtitles which was nice because
that was a little noisy where I was
watching so I kind of appreciated that
and at first we were like what did we
just rent like this is horrific and then
towards the end like it was pretty good
I won when I cried it had a lot of words
and if you're looking for a dumb movie
to watch like truly dumb you should
watch it it starts off so bad he was on
my plane I'm like I'm watching this
trash I know it's pure trash but they
had a lot of heart and she's a great
actress the only thing I couldn't
reconcile is like she was on watch what
happens right live recently being a
freak oh and I was just like I know too
much
yeah um no that movie literally looks
like the epitome of garbage trash no
it's garbage trash but it but it had
heart that's the best way to describe it
trash with heart like us like us cool
so I would recommend it um are you ready
to get into the next or do you feel good
about yeah I just I feel good about
catching up the wedding was still
basically when I asked you how is
Columbia all you told me that was the
fight you know because that's the only
thing to know well wait sorry what was
so funny about room the reason why I
brought it up it sorry
it's because like for me I'm on a plane
and like the time never ends it's like
six it was six hours I'm like it never
ends I'm like damn brie Larson was in
that room for seven years I'm like if
she like if she can stay in this room
for seven years I could stay in this
light for six years six hours thanks for
letting me know when she gets out oh
please please boy did you see it no not
yeah but it's next oh sorry sorry I
thought you saw it I'm so sorry well
just we'll figure it out little children
till Wednesday you guys catch up yeah
Armani start looking forward to watching
them we started a thing called movie of
the week
it honestly happened very organically
and this week I chose a little children
just because it's a very bizarre movie
with very famous people that like never
was popular and it's very hard to find
I've heard people are had to buy it on
Amazon or Google Play and it's just a
weird-ass movie and I think it'd be
funny to discuss why should we watch it
because I don't really I look forward to
being like turned around but I'm not
looking forward much because it sounds
like a horror story okay next up this is
what everyone's talking about it's the
only thing I'm interested in today
Kourtney Kim and Khloe Kardashian battle
it out on Twitter after Keeping Up with
the Kardashians fight family sticks
together no matter what and the
Kardashians are certainly no exception
after the season premiere of keeping up
this evening Kourtney Kardashian took to
Twitter to share her thoughts after
reliving the sibling battle that's now
been seen around the world so let's just
recap the episode because it was
everything honestly if you didn't see it
just still don't listen to this because
it's better than the episode like we on
Friday we recap the clips that were
coming out about this fight yes Lee and
honestly they released the whole fight
like there wasn't anything on the
episode that I hadn't seen on Instagram
and honestly good fur for Kardashian's
for like being in tune with what's
necessary in terms of social I'm
realizing that like this would get
people to watch because it really did
Kim is planning the fam
Christmas card between all saw and it
turned out to be a disaster I and now we
understand why because I was saying on
Friday she's like giving like on the one
she's right about everything Courtney is
the least busy they shouldn't have to
work around her schedule but at the end
of the day the Christmas cards suck they
could have film they could have taken
those pictures in ten minutes it was 15
25 shitty pictures candids but the
reason why it was like that it's cuz no
one could get their [ __ ] together so Kim
basically for the past two years they
haven't done their iconic Christmas card
because it's so hard to get like all ten
of them on the same day available in LA
like in a studio because they all work
so much so Kim was like this year I
wanted to it like and honestly Kim's
motive behind it was so sweet she was
like we just we have so many kids now
and like it's so nice to have these
memories I'm like these pictures that'll
last forever and it was like super sweet
and everyone was like I'll do it but I
don't want to help you and Kim was like
you know what Kim committed to making it
work so Kendall had a shoot
Chloe is pregnant Kylie was pregnant Kim
was launching her Kylie wasn't in it at
all but she never said she was gonna be
yep kya Kim is launching k'kaw holiday
holiday clutch in and Kourtney is just
being a full-time [ __ ] Organic mom and
Kim's trying to make it work trying to
book the glam trying to find the studio
to do it while the kids are after after
the kids are in school she didn't want
to pull the kids from school very
responsible and Kourtney is just being
unbelievably difficult she will not make
any time work that doesn't work for her
and it's not like she is Kim is like I
have these meetings early in the day
that are so important like if I don't
have them I won't be able to watch my
collection on time so and then the kids
are in school so if we do it afterwards
it works for everyone
Kourtney no no kids no meetings nothing
to do just doesn't want to be home past
six is making a big [ __ ] frenzy Afra
about the whole thing
so unaccommodating refuses to show up
says she's gonna leave after two hours
kendall has actual work so that's why
they have to push it even later and
everyone's okay with it except of course
Kourtney the girl who has no job she is
a girl with no job no 100% I want to say
it's actually the MVP of episode was
Kendall watching her come from her
adidas shoot sad alone and then she like
gave it her all like she was being like
cute fun a really good model and just
like a team player right I had a new
respect for her so after all the drama
they did they did it for Kourtney
they went according to Courtney schedule
she was still such a [ __ ] on set and
Kendyl showed up like late night when
everyone was gone and it was like it was
like sad it was it made me sad and like
she was such a good sport about it and
that we I was talking [ __ ] about Kendall
on Friday and I have less [ __ ] to talk
today because she's a she's a team
player
as I love Kylie so much like she's truly
my favorite but she's not on the show
anymore which is really hard for me
because I love her and she's like not
being a team player which is which isn't
I feel like she has her reasons like the
show must be really hard for her to do
like mentally capable in her life all
the time but ya know I hate that she's
sound on the show and it seems like
everyone's kind of okay with that and
that's what Courtney was saying so there
were so many interesting oh my god okay
in their fight so people keep saying
like this is her press this is her press
and it is and I thought the tweets last
night were definitely for press but this
fight was so real because you could tell
when Courtney can't stop crying you know
when we fight and like you start to cry
and it's not even like you're that upset
you just can't stop crying because it's
family like it was so real and I don't I
don't believe anyone who says this fight
was fake the tweets were definitely
stupid I think but this fight was so
real and they were saying little nuggets
of information that were just saw Sally
Donna Shay so town Courtney said if I
had enough money I went into this stupid
disgusting show like Kylie Kylie has
enough money she doesn't need you to
show sue and when they don't have enough
money that's one thing bro remember like
a couple years ago they signed a 10-year
deal for 100 million dollars and they
definitely all split it in certain ways
Kylie's definitely not taking that
anymore because she's like she's reneged
that's what Courtney was saying I if I
had enough money I wouldn't do this
stupid disgusting show like the [ __ ] she
was saying about our family like okay
that's stuff like the people that's what
what the public says like they're
disgusting and have no values and fine
if you feel that way that's a fair
that's a fair assessment but to like
enjoy the fruits of your sister's labor
like you live in a huge mansion and have
a ton of money for doing virtually
nothing off of Kim's back and off of
Kim's sex tape like you can't enjoy that
while also saying your family's
discussing and has values and you want
nothing to do with them pick a lane no
you either hate your family and are not
gonna enjoy anything that they give you
their honorable or shut up and go to the
shoot
totally and when Kim was like this is
all her therapist talking like because
who would say that about your own family
like without someone having told that to
you about your family who's about that
family definitely goes
she's like I'm Kourtney Kardashian and
I'm struggling and she was like well
you're in the discussing family so no
wonder right and so she comes back I'm
in a disgusting family I don't want to
be a part of it and like it was just
there were so many things that like
we're just so real like you know like
like we we're very similar in the sense
like sometimes you're like in a bad mood
and like you're mean and then everyone
lickings up and you it gets worse like
huh that happens Cyril so when
Courtney's sitting on the deck outside
she's like being mean about the
furniture and like you like that was so
[ __ ] and it was like it doesn't seem
like a big deal but like when you when
you're in that position like when you're
in like a bad place and you're just
being mean to everyone for literally no
reason then like everyone starts to hate
you and then it literally turns into a
fight like that is so real that is so
real except I really don't relate to
that like oh none of us ever you just
show up like and start swinging insults
I think some no not insults but like if
you're in a bad mood and you're like
creepy and like you rub someone the
wrong way then it turns into insults but
like if you just like I definitely
you're the wrong way she showed up the
wrong way totally she just is the wrong
way ya know and I can't believe we're
it's very much on Kourtney side because
they're saying like that she your mom
shaming her these did she's mom she me
right essentially if you say that you're
a mom like you win the argument I don't
know he was a mom too she's saying that
Kim's the bad mommy doesn't care right
and she's like and that's what she was
tweeting at Kim she's like no I mean
we're just different moms like basically
saying like I'm a better mom because I
like hands-on right and I just I don't
agree with that Nats mom shaming I'm
like good for you Kourtney like you have
the ability the luxury to decide not to
work but that's not the case for
everyone
so many moms don't have that luck right
also what was so interesting when Chloe
was like telling her that all she needs
to do is be on time like when they're
also when Kim was sitting on Kourtney's
couch I was like wow it's so cute they
just like hang out like that even when
they're not getting along that well
that's the work that she's talking I was
thinking the same thing and here's the
thing no one else is filming so if
Kourtney really like when Kourtney
doesn't film it's just on Kim and Chloe
and like Kim is the busiest one of them
all and Chloe and honestly yet so many
dumb scenes with Jonathan and Malika
because a lot and CeCe except I thought
that was interesting
why won't they say Sophia's name when
Kim was like when when Kendall like hi
they were hanging out with your
girlfriend ten years ago do you
everything she would be dating
Courtney's boyfriend I was good yeah but
you know what I'd rather see Sophie on
the show right now
same no Courtney's pissing me off so
much and it's like it's like with
Carolyn Bethenny like I can't believe
there are people who disagree with me
like I can't believe that there are
people who are on Team Courtney because
it just seems like she has her
priorities in order but but it's it's a
Friday I didn't know that she didn't go
to Kim's baby shower like I didn't
realize at the time I thought it was
gonna be like a date and then she gets
there yeah she knows like that's
unforgivable yeah that's unforgivable
like that that's where it's like you're
your sister so like no matter how mad
you are of course you still come that's
crazy it's so Willy doesn't want to be a
Kardashian anymore when it's like then
what the [ __ ] would you be being [ __ ] I
know a whole line of people who would
switch box with you hello we're ready so
ungrateful ready willing and able and
like I'm just like I'm so annoyed
because I feel like and do there's clips
for when the fight continues like
apparently takes over the whole season
and Kourtney's like going through
something right and we're gonna find out
what it was she's like why she's so
inherently unhappy but she says he's
just taking too many vacations she's
like boyfriend I'm not interesting to
look at do you see what people on the
internet say about Kim versus me like oh
is that what she said yes and first of
all I had something to say
you definitely say things in anger when
you're in a fight when Kim said she's
not even that interesting to look at I
definitely mean but like I just want to
say like that is not that man no it's
not that mean I wish someone would say
you're not that interesting to look at
means I'm not ugly it's you're not
extraordinarily beautiful your average
leti I would love to just be like
average like I would look for someone
just to look at me but oh no in the
context of the Kardashians it's actually
a compliment because the rest of them
are almost like cartoon so she's the
least cartoonish of them all that's a
compliment like there really is enough
and I think Kourtney would agree with
that that she is like Kendall's the
tallest kylie is like lips interesting
Chloe is very interesting to look at and
came in her booty totally like I didn't
think it was that big video about her
acting like it was like this devil like
the worst thing she ever heard like a
relaxed [ __ ] like I was getting so
heated and so invested Anna and they
were getting a ton of [ __ ] like after
the episode for just being like a big
fake press machine and they are and
those tweets like the fake 20 on Twitter
was simply stupid but this fight was so
real as someone who has sisters and one
who was fought it was so real
Courtney was like it was almost two
years when Courtney couldn't stop crying
in the kitchen like you know what that's
like when you can't get your words out
cuz you just can't surprise like I know
what that's like it's like stuff like
this like I actually can't believe that
they air it I thought that they because
it happened so long ago it's like not
fresh for them anymore and you know and
they little while ago that sacrificing a
little bit of your ego for the sake of
the show goes a long way and they
stopped caring a while ago so it doesn't
surprise me actually that they let this
like deep fight like if we reality show
we would like be so fake we wouldn't
want our real fights we just like fight
off camera ten years of being like you
we would because what who cares if
people know that we fight versus like we
have millions and trillions of dollars
yeah sure yeah I'll be fine I manage it
you like lose some of your values I
guess I say I can see how they go no she
was being so annoying really pissing me
off and like it was honestly like I
haven't felt that way about an episode
of Keeping Up with her actions since
Kim's robbery like really invested like
the shows a little like useless now and
I feel like this season's gonna be like
really hard because only the three of
them are filming oh that's what I was
gonna say so yeah
when Courtney doesn't want to film Kim
has like a business and a life and
honestly this the entire lifetime of the
show Khloe has carried the show on her
back in the sense that she goes
everywhere she went to the Hamptons
she went to Miami she went to New York
she did Khloe and Lamar she's on every
[ __ ] episode she's never not been on
I see she's living in Cleveland she
comes back to film and she feels in
Dallas when Lamar was on the Mavericks
like homegirl and by the way like as she
should like she she's enjoying the
fruits of the family's labor and she's
putting in the work I agree that their
works there were a few seasons where it
came took a backseat because she didn't
want her kids on it yeah and then it
Kanye I didn't want to miss him like
really has a lot of respect for Chloe
because she realizes that about coming
it's just so interesting how the
dynamics shift because years ago
Kourtney and khloé were like so close
and they used to be so mean to Kim and
basically it's like they've reversed
like in used to be super emotional in
Kourtney but they can make fun of her
for like having feelings and now and
Kourtney was like this hard like cos
Scott can't get to me like I'm a hard
heartless [ __ ] and now it's literally
opposite like nothing Kourtney said got
to Kim at all and Kourtney was being
like so overly emotional it's really
switched I think Kim has like been
proven that she's like right that she's
working so hard for her family and she's
earned the right to say
what the [ __ ] she she really has not
even what she wants just what's obvious
I don't need to buy her shoes I bought
her a [ __ ] career the greatest love
ever so true who was that about I think
who's that Courtney okay we need to move
on because I generally care we have such
a busy show we'll take the next story's
really quickly up t on the budget really
quickly really quickly so I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry
but Christian are getting involved like
Courtney you are being annoying like
she's supposed to be the mom sort of
things escalated yeah and then after
what she didn't have Courtney's back she
didn't okay job because she doesn't have
much power there no but mom like moms
are really supposed to be neutral and
when at Kim's birthday dinner when she
was like it's fine I got ten years of
being your favorite Kylie's your
favorite now it's so funny how they're
so me and also their new like aesthetic
and true and then between every scenes
like what the film does make me a little
nauseous I love that song that Kanye
song so I love that they used it but the
flipping of the old school film was
making me nauseous Oh usually that's
that's gonna make me nauseous and
usually it would okay
update on the Brady Bunch house as we
reported it was for sale Lance Bass said
they accepted my offer on the Brady
Bunch house but in an unfortunate turn
of events he is no longer the proud
owner he said he was feeling heartbroken
after learning he was outbid by an
apparent Hollywood studio he said how is
this fair illegal bass wrote in a
lengthy social media post how can I
compete with a billion dollar corporate
entity I truly believed I was I was used
to drive up the price of the home
knowing very well that this corporation
intend and I'm making their offer and
it's not a good feeling I feel used but
most importantly I'm hurt and Santa
saddened by this questionable outcome
that's [ __ ] sad okay that's what you
get for like being making a whole media
storm before you have signed paperwork
that's when you don't eat your chickens
before they hatch yeah like yeah like
honestly Lance Bass was just the thirst
monster and he couldn't keep the thirst
inside any longer but like sine go into
escrow [ __ ] before you make your stay
like that's how you get and even though
I do that all the time and we do that
all the time we like announce things
afar there we don't really don't like we
really try not to but we also we do the
best that we can but this isn't as big
as a home um
and lines fast you played yourself how
much he loves Ben's bid did they say I
don't know any of it public no it was
one point eight million they were
asking for like how does Lenz best have
any money like he's done a good job of
remaining relevant post NSYNC even
though literally the only other member
who's remained relevant is Justin
Timberlake for obvious reasons so it's
admirable but I don't find that he's
like working a lot like I don't know how
he has money like he's friends with Kris
Jenner so that's really kept him alive
especially on Instagram but what what
does he's married yeah and he's like a
fake host you know yeah I mean I'm a
fake host and I'm not purchasing a house
for 1.8 I would love to its some taxes
yeah you never know okay next up because
we're moving right along
395 people were sickened in McDonald
salad outbreak that's what you get for
ordering a salad at McDonald it's really
true federal health officials reported
Thursday an additional 109 cases of site
clasper infection in an ongoing outbreak
linked to McDonald's salads that began
in May the total number of laboratory
confirmed illnesses from this outbreak
is now 395 according to a statement from
the US FDA at least 16 of the sick
individuals have been hospitalized
honestly like seriously that's what you
get for ordering a salad like in the
[ __ ] at McDonough totally like
they're not it's not the place it's not
the place and they're clearly not
prioritizing their salads not okay look
if you want to help the alternative on a
budget like there are places now it's
not like the only option is McDonald's
for sure everyone it's on the shaker
that's what I was gonna say like that's
what you got McDonald's for getting rid
of the shake salad what was weird
yeah like a salad in a cup and you would
like shake it with the dresser [ __ ]
genius yeah
the shake and bake I don't know what it
was called we do so weird that we just
like said the same thing at the same
time I mean it's cuz we've had the whole
same life experience so that's that's
it's true we've had the whole same life
experience so interesting so interesting
it was even Wilder and I was talking
about with Ben cuz you wrote in the chat
that this week or this month is your
20-year friendship anniversary with your
friend Mario in a year but we're coming
up on our 20-year friendship anniversary
hasn't met at camp when you were six
thousand set up in to the year 2000 not
much as Chang but they lived underwater
that's a great song um that's just makes
me feel old you know it makes me feel so
old like I have a 20-year friendship I
feel like that's what Kris Jenner says
about her friend I don't have a 20-year
friendship like my oldest friend right I
don't have that like my the friend that
I've known the longest that you've been
friends with
right but and then I'm still friends
with my dad that's the hard part that's
why I cherish our friendship so much
like you mean way back when Kristin oh
that's a good call
cuz we knew Kristin when we were like 10
no we were still at MIGA when we were 10
Kristin and I became friends in the year
2010 we're coming up on 10 years no
because yes we were counselors together
yeah but we knew her before no doesn't
count okay
it's when the friendship started so yeah
like my real friends and my friends were
like eighth grade but check isn't that
long ago when I was graduated in 2008
you want to know what's so funny happen
for 10 years when I was in like grades
the Year always aligned like an aide
told us this before oh and it's very
nice for you know new toasters I'll tell
them now it's helpful for me because
that makes me was it two years after so
every year when I was in a grade like in
the third grade it was 2003 and in the
fourth grade it was 2004 and I thought
that L like it worked for everyone I
just didn't realize like my ears and
grades lined up and now it's so easy for
me to remember what grade I was in in
what particular year because it's like
oh fourth grade mm bored oh that's
convenient for me for three thousand two
no fourth grade well 2001 to 2002
because I remember 9/11 happened in the
fourth grade and then I take it from
there well yeah the first three months
like September October November those
don't really count for me because that
was a year before but whatever right so
it's just it's so hard anyways
congratulations on my almost 20 year
anniversary that's crazy but it's in a
long time but we're just realizing we're
coming up on him it's just so nice havin
a new me like before I even had a
personality yes watch me go through
every phase of my life so true and we've
Emden flowed we went to college and
we're probably like a year stretch as we
didn't see each other but now we're back
to where we used to be no but like you
guys when we lived in Long Island you
guys used to meet on the highway like
halfway between cuz shield in the city
and we lived in Long Island
it was just meet halfway yeah and the
Dunkin Donuts that's how important our
friendship was to us like we used to
make our parents organize it so there's
little pipsqueaks
totally so it's just nice like every
week we had such a nice weekend together
in the book it's really nice when I was
on my six hour plane ride like a you
were in the Hamptons it's fine I took a
three-hour jitney last night oh my god
tortured the Jedi that did you the
ambassador no I did the luxury line
there was luxurious about it but have
you been on the regular one now okay
it's like $10 more and it's so much
what's so worth it if it has that good
snacks cool fish obviously
hmm so another one fizz and final story
before we get into to your toasters
peloton raises five hundred and fifty
million dollars at a valuation of four
billion dollars oh you know what fellas
honey it's like stupid bike at home
SoulCycle oh my god that is so stupid
how much does one peloton cost probably
a couple of G's right that's like 10
years of SoulCycle and it's also gonna
you get to make friends I don't know no
I don't know I think it's definitely
worth it it's some people it's made for
people don't have a soul cycle nearby or
people who work from home right like mom
yeah or Shannon beador and then she
can't get off you know Schumer does it
really
she didn't Instagram once it's so funny
I did when I was engaged I did this
shoot for the knot and it was like
engaged influencers from like every
different um like genre category I was
obviously like humor and there was a
girl from fitness and there was an NBA
WNBA player and the girl from fitness
they all like I'm not trying to be that
shy guys they all have like you know a
hundred thousand a net and the fitness
girl for some reason I see her
everywhere like on Instagram she's
killing it and she's a peloton
instructor and Amy Schumer put up a
picture like she's like peloton at the
girl and I might be decepticons of this
she with and she's like one of the most
famous instructors on peloton that's so
quick you know the first time I heard
about peloton stifling no no matter for
a long time where Nicole Brooklyn's mom
Michelle she did it she was like an
early adapter of peloton so I'm like I
think they have commercials that's how I
heard about it well it's $3,000 for a
bike we found out and that really adds
up because to that reason I'm out
well they they're little bit horrific
shark team this is shark team come to
life oh my god peloton today announced
its Series s funding of five hundred and
fifty million dollars that brings the
total amount raised according to crunch
base to nine hundred and ninety four
point seven million according to the
announcement this round puts peloton
valuation at four billion dollars it was
just last May the company hit unicorn
status TCB led the round with other
participation in the round from Tiger
global remember these names true
ventures Wellington management fidelity
NBC Universal and kleiner perkins along
with new investors Felix capital and
Winslow capital you gotta get some of
these VCS up to toast I
wonder if the NBCUniversal investment
ship had anything to do with Shannon
beador getting stuck on her bike I don't
know
that would be real vertical integration
jack donaghy it really would be only
jack down I mean with the weight
speaking of shark tank um I know I'm
catching up on the most recent season
it's Shark Tank is literally my favorite
show and I just think there's so much to
be said about it and I'm almost done and
I'm loving they've done a great job of
incorporating guests but last night I
saw an update update on Friday the shark
tank updates are the best part of
episode 8 which they should have a whole
separate show just on updates because I
find it wildly interesting and there was
the guys from plated and I didn't know
that plated was on shark tank I don't
remember that episode but apparently
they signed a deal with Mark Cuban and
they did the update and they're like hey
we signed with Mark Cuban I'm like oh
whoa did you ask you together oh but the
deal never went through it's so
interesting and they don't tell you that
and I think BuzzFeed did an article once
like ten things you don't know about
behind the scenes Shark Tank 50% of the
deals don't go through because people
like live how do you know that those
people are telling the jurors on the
show like that their margins are so and
so so people lie I guess people change
your minds I don't know they they didn't
end up doing a deal with Mark Cuban but
because of the show and because it was a
good product plated ended up taking off
relatively well after shark tank and on
their way to the top they ran into Kevin
O'Leary and he ended up investing with
them he stole mark Co and literally like
a couple months ago plated was sold to
Albertsons for 300 billion dollars and
they're on track to do a billion dollars
in revenue this year so I just thought
that was like the most wild update ever
and I'm just I'm loving watching shark
tank and I love they moved some of the
people around Robert Herjavec it's now
at the front love him the worst the
absolute worst the war shark he's not
the worst shark there was the worst
shark depends on the day really but
sometimes like mr. wonderful is just too
mean for me no oh my god he is so epic
Daymond like doesn't do much for me I
used to love Daymond and now I'm really
over him he seems like super
disinterested like he doesn't even want
to be there he very rarely invests like
and I always make fun of Robert for not
investing but Daymond like never invests
but the thing about Daymond is he has
really good reasons for not investing
like when Robert wants to go out he
always repeats what like mark says he's
like like Mark said you know I just
don't think that solves a problem you
know Barbara said it best you know the
quality is not there for me like he
never comes up with his own original I
as to why he's not investing he just
sees other people doing it and he's
never the first to go out he's always
like the third of the face shark he's
not the shark yes no mark that shark
seems like he's the one I would probably
want to have as a friend no I would love
to market Mark Cuban's friend yeah yeah
and I wish they did more than one
episode with Bethenny because I thought
she was great
and I think they'll bring her back as
the reception has been so positive and
because she's friends with all them now
she went to the birthday party
I just utter I want to see more I'd like
Rohan I think he's really smart I feel
like he has potential to be a full time
shark for sure because he brings in an
area well an area of expertise and is
specific like branding expertise but the
others they probably have branding
consultants on their team like yep I
just feel like he has a lot of vision
it's actually really interesting how
they all kind of have their own niche
niche like Mark is like tech software
anything digital sports yeah Barbara is
I don't know
Daymond is like clothes anything
material texture textiles mr. wonderful
is wine and education like anything
because he sold his company good product
yeah yeah royalties home bori I find
we're good
Lori is I think the unsung here I think
it's very hard to be a woman on the show
and bar she's only full-time woman
Barbara rotates out and Barbara like
very rarely invest in stuff and she's
like like half in half out Lori is only
full-time woman I think that she has
such a good eye and I find her to be
just like really smart and I really
trust her and she doesn't listen to what
other people say and then follow along
she's really like her own independent
thinker for sure we need to be really
actually and no michio because we just
have so much to do and we need to talk
to Dominique and there's just so much to
do and we need to give you guys advice
to your toasters okay ready ready hi
Claudia Jackie so I work by the way dear
toasters at gmail.com if you want us
next week to talk about some of your
problems and it's all anonymous don't
worry so I work at a financial
institution with a bunch of fellow
toasters between the stocks and bonds
and handling of millions of other people
millions of dollars of other people's
money you know we have to stay in tune
of what's necessary and meet at the
watercooler at 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
this is so interesting so we had a new
sales hire recently John Serhant
he's Ryan Serhant younger brother from
Selleck sir Hannah Bravo being huge
Bravo bender's as it is we are all
slightly dying that
work with a d-list celebrities brother
we used to be last I would say yeah I
just really need to approach it in some
way because I feel like he has to know
some behind-the-scenes details I know if
I don't address this soon I'm gonna get
drunk at an after-work luncheon and say
something ridiculous and demand any
comments phone number please advise and
let me know how we should handle should
I confront him about it and try to get
some premium content between the excels
in the training things aren't really
popping here I mean need a distraction
keeping it toasty Sally in the gang at
the water cooler so cute yeah you guys
go up some he's probably he's new he's
probably like looking make friends he's
probably so excited that you guys even
know who he who his brother is you
probably are all like so cute and he's
probably like oh my god yeah well this
kid it's like his brothers Leonardo
DiCaprio like you described it girls
Ryan just ran he's probably so excited
go Birds just subject and honestly if
you wait till you're drunk and you bring
it up he's gonna think you guys are like
mega fans and like it's just Ryan
Serhant just go this is the best way to
do it okay you be John okay okay hi I'm
Sally hey Sally I'm John hey John I'm
John 1 John Sirhan I just started here
I'm on the sales team oh cool like um
like that guy writes her hand I love
that job oh that's actually my brother
oh my gosh no way that's so cool are you
guys close no we're strange I hate
talking about it so thanks for bring me
up I'm gonna go cry the bathroom now see
that's worst-case scenario that wasn't
even that bad totally go talk to him
don't wait til an after-work function
being the new person I work as hard so
like I'm sure he's just happy to have an
in with some cool peeps who are hanging
out at the water cooler maybe tell him
about the toast
many new Edson start like open came on
the toast it's a great segue be like we
start your brother on our favorite
morning show we all watch together 10:30
amen
wanna join us in conference room and
come join us that's it
hey I'll bring the doughnut I feel like
no matter what office building urine
there's always a conference room area
for hijacking Claudia I'm about to be a
senior in college and have been
interning in New York City this summer
the company I'm interning for is a well
known company and I was so excited when
I got the job I've been here for over a
month and most days I said at my desk
all day bored because they have nothing
for me to do I used to constantly ask if
there was anything else I could do and
they never gave me anything so I felt
like I was just being annoying they are
paying me but it's not at all so it's
not at all bad but it's very frustrating
I'm spending more money to be in New
York City than I am making at this
internship and I feel like I'm wasting
my time the other dinner
intern I work feels as I work with feels
the same way and we've been to each
other about it all the time I'm often on
my phone because I'm so bored but I feel
like I look like the lazy intern on her
phone because it's always but it's only
because I'm bored out of my mind I just
can't take the boredom any more than I
need
this is such a classic intern problem I
have so many internships throughout
college and literally they just hire you
because they have to and there's nothing
for you to do and you start off being
like you know bright-eyed and
bushy-tailed like hey is everything I
can help with and you would ask before
you could leave and then like they don't
even care so you just like leave at 3
o'clock I'm like no one's looking for
you here's the thing it's not about you
this company is running they needed to
hire interns you're a hand when they
need it but it's not about what work
you're doing or if you're interested or
driven enough by your work be grateful
that you don't have to do much you can
spend all your time on Facebook one day
you'll have a very demanding job and
you'll wish back for these days your
internship isn't worthless because the
only point of having an internship is to
say that you had an internship it
doesn't matter what you actually did
there I need to tell you so stop making
it about you you're the intern you're
there when they need you and enjoy your
free time money you write money writing
short stories right so that's what I was
gonna say I'm like a big do you summer
reading I'm big on time management like
when I was in college there were classes
like a lecture like you don't really
listen you just like sit on your
computer but I would use that instead of
like sitting on my computer for an hour
and 15 minutes I would do my homework
from other classes so by the time I got
home I could just lay and watch TV like
time management's so important it's like
look you have a an office it's you said
it's a big company so you have a
state-of-the-art office it's printing
and Excel is there anything you're
passionate about use it to start a
business like there's so many people who
start businesses I'm watching shark tank
at their desks like and their other jobs
and nobody cares like you're not the
only person who has a job that's not
fulfilling in terms of like actual
workload it's like use your time wisely
like I think time management people who
manage their time well are like so ahead
of the curve your bosses aren't sitting
around all day wondering how you're
doing what you should be doing so like
it's not about you starting wisely and
stop complaining and one day you're
gonna have more work thing you know what
you do with thing you're gonna wish back
for these days of simpleness these days
these days we're just breezing through
these your toasters this one's super
interesting I'd been using dating apps
like tinder and bubble for a while now
as a trans woman I feel it's easier and
more safe to meet men this way since I
clearly state that I'm trans in my bio
so if it isn't for them they can just
keep moving
anyway I'm after this guy a couple
months ago we started talking instantly
and he was so sweet funny and sincere
after some Facebook stalking I
discovered that I knew his family
basically his dad and stepmother are
good friends with my parents such good
friends in fact that they were in
attendance at my college graduation
party a few years ago I struggled with
what to do with this information but
ultimately
ultimately decided to share what I
discovered he didn't seem to care much
at all but he made it clear that we
should keep things between it just
between us after about a week we hung
out and it was a nice time we started
seeing each other a couple times a week
and I started to really like him we had
sex after like three weeks and he made
it clear again that this is just to stay
between us at first I didn't really mind
because I just figured he wanted to be
private with this dating life but now
I'm starting to think he doesn't want
people to know about it because I'm
trans he made it clear before we found
out about our mutual connection that he
was looking for more than just to hook
up but after this information surfaced
it doesn't seem like he wants to commit
in any way because of it I asked him
what his intentions were with me after a
few weeks and he said we're having fun
and just enjoying ourselves right now
and I'm not saying I wanted to scream it
from the rooftops and tell every single
person in this life about me but I'm
starting to fall for him and they don't
want to feel this way if it isn't gonna
be reciprocated
he says he's into me and we have a lot
of fun together but he's not ready to
tell people because he's quote-unquote
private how do I let him know that I'm
not comfortable being his secret without
coming on too strong it's only been
about two months so I don't want to seem
like a major commitment like I want to
meet your commitment but some validation
would make me feel less shitty for lack
of a better term
thanks guys love you both that's the
worst feeling like feeling like like
someone's ashamed to be oh yeah and this
is what I need to know
Frick sure did you did he say he wanted
to keep things cool in private before
cuz as much as it's a shock to me there
are people who don't want to like you
know put their whole lives out there and
I don't understand it I didn't thanks
right jump in you guys have no or only
when I told him that you had mutual
friends right so that's important but
there's literally a special place in
house for like boys who like are ashamed
of girls that they're dating like maybe
always like they're like I want to keep
it private and either it's because like
they don't think you're friends but like
you they don't think you're good enough
like they're that's happened many times
and we got a bunch of deer toasters like
that and like there's a special place in
hell right behind guys who call girls
fat right behind them waiting in line to
go to hell these guys who like he keeps
it like secret relationships because
they're like embarrassed of what their
friends will think right I think I'd
love to see what you look like well so I
feel like before you really start
falling for him like definitely keep
your guard up and also like test him a
little bit if you guys aren't exclusive
but you think he's into you and like he
would be upset by the loss of your
relationship grow on the table oh no
someone else they'd make it clear that
you are seeing other people and the only
way for him to have you all to himself
is to lock it down right and take it
I can make it official but that's like
the worst position to be in when you
have like a legitimate concern but you
don't want to come off as being a I want
to get married so you don't say it but
then you end up like six months down the
road like finding out what you thought
you already knew and you could have
saved so much time if you've just been
open about it but then he would have
thought you were like really date it's a
very delicate balance and I think that I
always just I never am like open I would
always just like be playing hard-to-get
make myself scarce see how much you're
really into me make yourself scarce yeah
you stopped answering his texts little
bit cuz now you're always there when he
needs you oh my god that is literally
like girls are always just like they
think it's so complicated you know yeah
and here's the thing if you want to
gotta like you you just don't answer
their texts like the first three months
that I met Ben I was so psychotic
texting him calling him every second
like making him like FaceTime me for
hours like he definitely thought I was
annoying and rightfully so and then one
day I just stopped answering and two
weeks later Ben told me he loved me I
swear it's literally that simple boys
are so stupid just take hours to respond
don't like if he's like how are you be
like I'm good thanks like don't don't
ask how are you just make yourself
scared don't double text and like
they'll come around you don't have to
ignore them cuz then they'll think
you're mad at them but you don't care
enough to be mad at them right like if
you had like tentative plans like that
was like are we going to the movies I'm
like no sorry I'm gonna see the front of
my sister yeah like your tendons weren't
enough of a priority important enough
for me to remember
hold yourself scarcity is key keep us
updated please totally we have time for
three dear toasters say I'm so sorry oh
this one's interesting and it's
different I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
hi Claudia and Jackie my is she was one
of my friends who edits her pictures
like a lot and very badly to the point
where even my guy friends who don't
notice anything and girls that I'm not
even friendly with are noticing and
saying something to me and my other
friends make it worse if she posts a
picture with you in it she'll photoshop
your face and body too
I tried to approach her once about how
she posted a picture of me in my teeth
were edited so white and glowing you
could would have thought my teeth were
yellow and rotting and she was doing
your best to help me out for the record
my teeth are not yellow or rotting I
asked her why she had us her photos when
they don't need editing she immediately
got defensive and would not talk to me
about it since then the poor picture
editing has only gotten more notice of
all my friends and I are unsure how to
let her know that other people can tell
she's photoshopping her pictures and her
low-key making fun of her for it we want
her to know but we don't want her to get
her feelings hurt or get defensive do
you know of a Photoshop class we can set
her up for how would you approach a
situation that's so funny it seems like
you approached it and she first of all
people who Photoshop their pictures
beyond recognition like there's some
sort of like one like lack of self
awareness that you don't
realize that that is a cartoon and
that's like embarrassing seems like you
tried to say her in the nicest way
possible you only made it about the
teeth and she's still got defensive
brace stop taking pictures with her and
let her embarrass herself he's like she
clearly thinks that this is okay yeah
but like the key to being a good photo
editor is just that self-awareness like
you need to be able to look at the
original and at the Edit a photo and
like look in the background make sure
you're not like whack like and just be
able to remove yourself for a minute and
just look at it as like a third party
perspective you know definitely and also
like for me I mean she would never do
this so she's clearly going overboard
but sometimes all I can leave in
something that you would think why
wouldn't she if she were editing why
wouldn't she take that out like I need a
chunky thigh cuz you would be like I
might have made the rest of me smaller
right if I were editing why wouldn't I
mean my show - he's like you just have
to go what's believable yeah and like
just a level of deniability but anyway
it doesn't seem like there's any saving
her she's gonna have to you know what
she's gonna have to do she's gonna have
to go out on a date someone's gonna
realize she doesn't look like her
picture she's gonna learn the hard way
and then maybe she'll stop but until
then don't don't start a fight I'm gonna
take people who like can't be spoken to
you know I mean like if you have a small
problem even if no matter how big or
small like if someone comes to you in
like an honest way and just like has an
issue or like confronts you like and you
just aren't here for it like I can't
take people who are so like not easy to
talk to but something suit down like if
you said to me truly like Jax like
you've been over editing your photos
like I would hear you and then I owed
and clear we've definitely said that to
each other I'm under TechSoup are gonna
be like delete that like we all do it
and sometimes you need another person to
tell you because you're so involved in
know the way that you look you gotta
zoom at like you'd be so into it you're
like why not make my eyes bigger and
lips bigger teeth whiter and then you
forget to look at it all together right
so it really does help when it comes to
this to have someone honest and that's
why you always got to show it to someone
else yeah this sounds like a nightmare
yeah okay so we are gonna take a brief
pause and we are gonna go grab our guest
Dominick pen from wags if you have any
questions for her about wags about I
don't know anything or Instagram
anything like Hubbs
make sure to comment on the Facebook or
the YouTube stream and we will do our
best together questions Tirso just go
grab a drink grab a snack go to the
bathroom make a poop whatever Sally have
your morning toast we'll be back in a
couple minutes
you
okay we are back with the gorgeous
Dominica pen thank you for being here no
problem thank you for just chatting
because you were on say yes to the dress
how long ago oh my god
I would say about six years ago oh wow
the show's been on forever I mean
forever
I wanted to and I just wanted to hear
about your experience and dis repertory
play a lot girl I think I mean like some
checks because over gasps over and over
and over again and I didn't even realize
that people even kind of now see my mom
and they're like are you really like
that like did you not like let your
daughter and I'm like no she's really
like that in real life but the dynamic
was completely different right how it
aired for sure I get like messages in
like all the different languages because
they really play it like all around the
world like once a week it's crazy
hopefully globally we're a global brand
now yeah so what are you doing in New
York
I'm Simon work at the Jarvis Center at
Children's Club because I have a story
called Stoli of some more and this is
where we do our buying this is buying
season so I'm buying for our spot our
fall and our spring of next year
you know how fashion is always this
season ahead yeah so I'm actually happy
to be here just looking at everything
seeing the new news and the baby trans
and clothings and items and things like
that so working that's amazing point but
last season was your first season of
wags yes how did you enjoy the
experience you know it was a great
experience for me because it came like
right on time but I don't think it
really just showed who I was I am a fun
person I'm all about women empowerment I
have my own businesses and I really felt
like they showed a lot of the other
women you know with clothing lines and
photo shoots and all this stuff enough
my hood up girlfriend like Dominique
that's a whole bunch of going on you
know I just might not be in the fashion
fashion world but I have a lot well and
I wish they were to show more of that so
are you on the next season no waxes
canceled oh my god Jackie's heart is
broken cancellation check bags la is
canceled no the whole franchise
said breaking news
dad breaking no one chose it so invested
in a show but the way to keep it Wyatt
yeah well I think there was changes to
you know the hit people of E they
brought on a whole new staff and
development team and I don't think it
just fit with what they were looking for
anymore so they decided to cancel it
that is so sad but Natalie and Olivia
are getting their own show their family
show that's what I heard I think I don't
train yeah I don't know if that's
confirmed but I know they're working on
something after you can't get out with
the Kardashians you're sure
working all songs so do you know how
they all know each other because now
they're like best friends and no one can
identify how or why you know what
they're really big in the beauty world
right so I think that that's probably
how they were able to meet you know Kim
or me - Kim I think you just hit it off
and they just hit it off
can we talk about the planet on your
finger oh this little girl
right on she's like no no you know it
was my wedding ring you know that's what
he it's beautiful thank you thank you
all of the WAGs always have like the
nicest rings they're huge and they're
like always falling off to the side
because you're small hands Ryan hole you
know what and it's I just always feel
like this is never enough I never miss
when you travel with that no absolutely
not insured oh absolutely
but you know I'm never I'm never really
scared to go anywhere I know like
certain places I wore my band of course
but you know I really don't look at it
like that it's a part of me it's a part
of who I am now so it doesn't really
make a difference well I'm not scared I
wish somebody would run up - it's a
weapon - yeah a few in luck someone I I
can cut someone's face with this table
you may be right right so are you still
friendly with the girls from the show do
you make any new friendships or if it's
just for me it was work I'm really my
whole time being a leg per se I've never
really gotten to it with any girls I've
never had any drama I'm just not that
type of person you know I'm very
straightforward so all that drama
kekeke and class act and that
not me right you know what I'm saying
however you do go through things with
women because you're meshing
personalities you're gelling and stuff
like that so I can just basically leave
the people in wax like where they are
got it
Jim or Michelle Michelle is my boo but
everybody else thinking they can stay
where they are
okay who did you know coming in Michelle
just Michelle Michelle because we share
the same stylist got it and then I met
autumn and Sasha together kind of like
at the same time and then of course
everyone watched the friendship unfold
and kind of refold unfold yeah that was
sad because you could tell there was a
lot of history there and then it's just
all over mostly probably from the show
yeah you know I think that anytime you
have real friendships not like just
people that you meet from work but real
deep friendships and you experience a
lot of things together like having
children getting married you know the
things that are very sentimental in
someone's life I think that it's more
than TV you know what I'm saying and I
feel like it was just so many emotions
going you know and I just feel like a
lot of it didn't need to be on TV and a
lot of it needed to be topped outside of
TV yeah you know what I'm saying but you
know I wish them both the best and how
did you deal with just going from being
like a regular gal to like having
cameras in your face 24/7 and having
like a whole millions of people who like
give a [ __ ] about what goes on in your
life you know what I never understood
and how people really gave a [ __ ] like
the tweets like I mean the tweets that I
mean you can't do anything wrong like I
can say for instance like I love redhead
women yeah you're marginalizing blonde
this right like hole up like first of
all I can say that I like that it's okay
but I really do I really like I can say
what I like I mean it has been a
different experience for me but I'm
built tough so it's whatever you know
yeah I don't see these people in my face
you know so they can just keep talking
how did your husband like being on the
show um I don't really think any man
wants to be on a girls show so he was
always like hesitant like
one scene where we were in his office
and we were talking and he was just like
I've been here forever right and then
I'm looking at it and I'm like oh my god
I can see the energy like you were just
like so blah yeah then it's another
scene when we're outside playing
basketball we were in our element you
know yeah it was cool
I just think no man really wants to be
that happens a lot like in very
Cavallari like it comes off like the
dude is like a dick but they're not like
they just don't want to be there like
understandably seeing the same thing
andrey filming over and taking time out
of their day over again and especially
when they're athletes they're tired most
of these men you know they're working
totally and they're pounding their
bodies you know to get conditioned so
after that they have to come and sit in
a hope and a you know all these cameras
you're like wait a minute
like I thought you'd only said this is
only gonna be an hour right I'm here for
five hour and it's ten seconds on TV
right and I just killed myself at the
gym to me ready for the season and now
I'm doing this for you so you know it's
annoying it is annoying for them it is
what is next for Dominique Penton Oh
what is next
everything is next okay well you know I
just really want my books to flourish I
am a children's author I have the mini
adventures of Donald children book
series Spanish French and Mandarin and I
would really like for that to you know
be a cartoon kind of like an animated
series so I'm working on that I have my
store of strollers and more and
hopefully you'll see more TV a nine
eight and we're we're can everyone will
keep up with you keep up with a story
you and your husband absolutely check me
out on Instagram and Dominic pin
underscore on Twitter
thank you so much for being here so nice
to meet you thank you guys for tuning in
we're back tomorrow Rachel Lindsay will
be filling in for me
recapping tonight's what will be the
most boring episode of that forever but
we'll see you that and I'll see ya
you